please welcome our good friend mr. Jack
Black
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was incredible we cut to commercial
yeah yeah no no we are not cutting a
commercial you don't have to catch her
you're gonna have to catch your breath
on television yeah no problem I love
that those elephant moves you have those
magical elfin moves there's a burst of
adrenaline that I get only when I step
onto the Conan stage yes the two minutes
of non-stop adrenaline yeah you're doing
a few minutes of heaven yeah you look
fantastic
I feel good I've got really good facial
hair yeah I got an awesome new shirt as
you can see I've got some moves you've
got the moves you've got a shirt with
ducks on it I believe Doc's are
fantastic
so there's best ducks in the biz breath
yeah yeah you're all dressed for the
holidays all right yeah good to see you
fine how are you I'm really good all
right yeah
notice how I'm giving you a lot of time
to catch your breath no it gets very
professional I don't want to catch my
breath this is part of my new shtick is
just being like out of breath is like a
great great thing to be yeah he sound
like a pervert on the phone
[Laughter]
you